Isis we haven't done anything on Isis in
a couple weeks and Isis also is sort of
fallen out of the news in the last month
although again we are at war right now
in Syria with no congressional
authorization have you heard me say that
yet but some interesting video and
pictures we've got some pictures for you
of Isis kids in training literally that
is what you're looking at right here
we've got five pictures for you so we're
going to scroll scroll through them
they're dubbed the Caliphate Cubs the
children appear to be a little more than
ten years old and are dressed in full
combat gear as they struggle to hold
weapons while standing in front of
Isis's infamous black flag and these
photos were released by the official
Islamic state media again not the first
time we've seen stuff like this we did a
video a couple months ago about this
Australian kid who's like 18 years old
who's like a leader for Isis right now
but these kids are like 10 yeah so so
what's the grossest part here is it now
there is now they're just the raw age
that the indoctrination has begun is
that is that the worst part here I don't
think this is new I'll say that no it's
not actually been doing this for a very
long time I think that they just are
targeting they know that there's a fear
fact you know it's terrorism and when we
talk about terror this is one of the
ways to accomplish it without even
committing any atrocities to show the
world exactly what they're doing I mean
it's very reminiscent to me of Hitler
Youth it's very reminiscent of this con
but we all know that this happens in
madrasahs anyway that it's like get them
while they're young indoctrinate them
and and now these are pretty much
soldiers for for Allah for Mohammed for
the Caliphate yeah I like so in a weird
way is this stuff more [ __ ] up than
the beheadings that's what I keep
thinking like the Manning is a one-shot
deal and you know they every few weeks
or whatever it is I'm not diminishing it
or minimizing it in any way but this
thing where they're taking these kids
and literally breeding this stuff that
is going to last for generations
yeah they turn them into robots I feel
like you know they're not even little
kids anymore it's like they've done so
much of this by the time they've reached
you know even a teenager or later on
into adulthood it's almost like second
nature to do terrorist attacks yes
feels normal so what can we do I'm
guessing that these bombings that we're
gonna do are not gonna stop them from
teaching kids if anything it just proves
they go oh look they're dropping bombs
on
us and then it gets the kids more so
what do we do I mean this is this is the
long game this is diplomacy you know
unfortunately that this is improving
educational efforts in parts of the
world that made neighbor Syria that made
neighbor Afghanistan that made neighbor
Iraq you know it's ensuring that there
will be individual anything why is it
every everyone hates the America for
coming in and then at the same time if
we don't go in these guys those
neighbors never seem to do it what's
well and and I think a lot of times it's
because they don't have as much ability
as we do I mean for us to come in from
across the the ocean and kind of put
troops on the ground or send missiles
over is a lot less risky than for a
neighboring country to invade and
especially when we're talking about
terror cells when we're talking about
things that aren't necessarily state
sanctioned it gets very complicated and
so I mean granted I am NOT an expert in
this kind of international conflict this
kind of diplomatic relations but I think
it's it's both you know when we bomb
madrasahs when we go in and we bomb
terrorist suspects it breeds more
terrorism we know that it's it's a
recruiting tool for Isis and I think
unfortunately this stuff is going to
happen until we start to see major
change affected in parts of the world
where there are pseudo democratic
governments taking hold where we see
individuals who are more who have
opportunities for education that didn't
have opportunities for education before
but it's a long game yeah very much I
don't know exactly where those are in
that part of the world but where where
the children's groups like where is
UNICEF or the UN or shouldn't this be
like something that everyone forgetting
yeah that's what I was just gonna say
like you talked about the United States
intervening and I think that's really
important but I think it's also really
important that it's not just us
otherwise people get irritated they say
oh the United States is just poking
their nose other people's business which
we've been known to do a few times
before and I think it's important that
when we actually do go and do these
things that we eventually leave yeah
because we have you know the reputation
staying in other countries for far too
long I mean like that 12-year thing that
we just signed with Afghanistan to be
there through 2024 like that thing yeah
yeah but I mean I think like in
situations like this children's groups
like you just said need to come together
and do something because we're hiding
because we're we're the kids going to go
like we're going to have to establish
refugee camps and unfortunately when you
look at you know the efforts at UNICEF
has had historically in for example
parts of Africa that are experiencing
civil war or that are experiencing
genocide those kids don't want to be
caught up in that so if they can escape
and go to a refugee camp that's where
they'll want to go these kids are not
going to willingly leave yeah they're so
indoctrinated that they're fighting now
for Isis and they feel very much a part
of Isis they feel a responsibility they
feel a pride in the work that they're
doing and it's a whole different
conversation at that point yeah and I
used to do a bit about this in my
standup literally ten years ago that if
we would just drop video games there
that they might rather play video games
than do that kind of stuff great idea
[Music]